so in your latest project The Last of Us
you play the role of Joel Miller a
character who much like the show has
this austere outer shell but Underneath
It All is a Warmness as an actor how do
you think about balancing the noble
traits that make a character like Joel
heroic versus the weaker ones that make
him human
you're smart
I never thought about it that way
um
I think that
there's a funny thing about a very sort
of restricted exterior that is typical
for these kinds of male archetypes I
think
don't show your feelings people will see
that you're weak survival is key don't
let anybody in you know
developing human connection is is not at
least in his mind key to survival but
then only to discover that he cannot
live without it at any cost